it's international day of yoga can you
tell we've we've left the set and now
we're sitting like this and we took her
shoes off well yeah i'm sitting on my
there you go
so okay we're joined with the wonderful
people at redemption fitness maria and
christina joining us today to talk about
yoga and i just mentioned this during
the break i thought this was so
incredible you mentioned recently in a
class that when you started doing
pilates in yoga you kind of reversed age
you move backward yes why is that why is
yoga so important
yoga is so important because it helps us
to increase the awareness of our body
and helps keep us in the here and now
so when you're present inside your body
you
feel amazing you're not in the past
you're not in the future you're right
there and you're present so that
awareness along with the breath
and the physical movement of the body is
just really a great way to heal
to revive your body to bring more energy
and just to bring more joy to your life
you know i i used to do yoga a lot more
than i ever have in the last couple of
years but i remember the first time i
walked in it's so daunting because
there's poses you have no idea what they
are and everybody else seems to know
what they're doing and you're kind of
like in the back of the class scared out
of your wits maybe that was just me
for people that maybe are interested in
doing something especially if they're
maybe at home right now uh this morning
what are just some simple
yoga poses just to get going just to get
started
some beginners just to get off the
ground
let's talk about that because really
there you don't have to show up to a
yoga class to get the yoga you can do
yoga at home all on your own you can do
it really anywhere anywhere where you
have space
so we're just going to start with a
really really simple what we call a cat
cali
cat cat
i can do this really really good for
your spine it's like a crunch for your
spine so what we're going to do is on
our inhale we're going to lower our back
and gaze up toward the sky and then our
exhale we're going to arch our back to
the sky and turn our gaze toward our
navel so inhale lower back dips down
eyes gaze up
and exhale really arch your back push it
up i already did my position
you can do it as well seated so if
you're in your chair like you have a
little break you can also do it seated
you can even do it just like this you
can just hold on to your knees and just
arch your back and then push forward so
for all the people who are stuck in an
office all day working behind a computer
that's something that can really like
stretch things out feel good
yes absolutely i like that because you
see some of the poses i know you guys
handstands and headstands and all this
kind of stuff it's hard it's hard to get
to that point yeah but it starts here
yeah
right the foundation of your practice
and then you can build on handstands and
headstands and float in the air and
whatnot yeah all right
i love it i love it and really quick
because of course we're running out of
time and there's never enough time
redemption fitness you guys don't just
offer yoga you have everything we saw
some of the video i mean boxing cycling
you name it pilates yes everything we
have everything all in under one roof um
one stop shop i love okay
let's be honest that's where i go so i
love you guys but it's so good to have
you guys here in the studio in henderson
you can go check them out and and you
know whether you just want to go and
breathe deep or you know breathe really
hard if you're running around
that's your favorite it may have
happened before thanks guys